the supreme court began hearing
arguments on the white house's
requirement that 80 million workers get
vaccinated the mandate is part of the
biden administration's push to increase
the country's vaccination rates at a
time when the omicron strain is sending
coveted case counts soaring now during
the hearing conservative justices appear
to have cast some doubt over the mandate
and a ruling could be made within a few
days if not sooner here now with more on
today's special hearing is bloomberg
news supreme court reporter greg store
greg always good to speak with you can
you start us off by giving us the quick
take on what was said today
yeah so this was an argument about
whether this this uh shot or test rule
can go into effect it's supposed to kick
in as soon as monday uh states and
business groups were arguing that it
should not be that the that osha went
beyond its authority and the bad
administration
is defending it saying we really need
this to stem the tide of kovic
now there's another white house rule out
there as well that would require shots
for workers in nursing homes and other
facilities that get funding from
medicare and medicaid is the court
likely to rule or lean the same way on
this
not necessarily it's two different
statutes govern governing them and
that's really what this is about it's
about uh when congress set up the
agencies osha and the center for
medicare and medicaid uh whether it gave
them the authority to do something like
this so the court doesn't have to come
out the same way and based on the
arguments the court was especially
skeptical about the osha rule and a
little more equivocal about the health
care rule
so let's take a step back here for a
moment and just consider the context
because i wonder how receptive the
supreme court is overall to other
vaccine mandates because i kind of
remember they rejected religious
objections to some vaccine rules how are
those different from what's being argued
today
yeah that's a really important question
those were all stated in this one case
local vaccine mandates and uh this is
all about the power of the federal
government and for some of the course
conservatives that's a huge difference
and in fact justice neil gorsuch brought
that up in the argument today he said
hey i rejected a challenge to one of
those state mandates
involving new mexico um but here we're
talking about something very different
we're talking about whether congress
authorized osha to do this and a number
of the conservative justices suggested
they didn't think congress had and that
maybe this was an area that that
congress should act in if the federal
government's going to have the authority
so it's less uh
a rule or less less consideration of the
fact that it's coveted and vaccines and
more on states rights and the reach of
the federal government is what it sounds
like
yeah i mean certainly the argument on
the other side is hey this is a huge
pandemic uh you know
hundreds of thousands of people had died
have died that's certainly the point the
court's liberal justices made and by the
administration as well
uh but the question is uh you know we've
known for a long time that the
possibility of this sort of pandemic is
out there and yet congress hasn't acted
and even during this pandemic congress
didn't explicitly give any of these
agencies the authority so the argument
goes uh and so maybe uh we need to wait
for congress to do something got it got
it so uh for the liberal side it's it's
all about you can't ignore and untie
kovid and the pandemic from any of this
there was a moment of irony here too
greg as well because the lawyers that
are representing the state apparently
they had covet or they tested positive
for kovit as well
yeah two of the lawyers who were arguing
from the states uh the lawyer for ohio
and the lawyer from louisiana uh both uh
apparently had positive tests it was a
mandatory rule at the court you have to
test take a pcr test the day before if
you test positive uh you have to argue
remotely and so that's what they did
the lawyer for ohio
spokesperson said that he'd actually
tested positive
after christmas and that there was some
lingering virus and that's why he tested
positive uh it's the first time that
role has been has kicked in it's the
first time a lawyer has had to go
remotely to argue a case because of
covet certainly ironic in this case
you've been covering the supreme court
and legal cases for decades now so let's
get into the supreme court not minutia
but some some expertise here in terms of
today was not a full briefing this was a
special session what's different about
these special sessions from what
normally happens
yeah so so what this was were a series
of stay applications those are the
emergency requests that the court gets
that it almost always decides just based
on the briefing and usually in a matter
of days this is not one of these cases
where the court says we're going to take
this case up on the merits do a whole
new round of briefing a lot of amicus
briefs friend of the court briefs uh so
this is the first time since i've been
covering the court for over a couple
decades that the court has done anything
like this um it comes amid all this
criticism of how they've been handling
the so-called shadow docket all these
emergency requests uh there have been
calls for greater transparency and that
may be part of what was going on here
why the court decided we want to hear
arguments and really have a chance to
think through and flesh out our reasons
so what's next greg what what should we
be looking for
well we could get something very soon
as i suggested the rule is scheduled
that the ocean rule is scheduled to kick
in next week um
the administration has said we're not
actually going to start citing
slapping companies with citations unless
they're acting in bad faith until
february still you could see the court
especially if it's inclined to block
this rule wanting to act very quickly
so that companies know from the get-go
that this rule is indeed blocked got it
greg store thank you so much bloomberg
news supreme court reporter joining us
on the latest with the supreme court
considering the biden administration's
rule that 80 million workers get
vaccinated